Hey everyone, Jared here, and today we’re
talking about the blackhole that devoured
weeks of my life: Fallout 4.
Like many of its predecessors, Fallout 4 follows
a vault dweller bravely traversing
the post-apocalyptic Wasteland.
Unlike Fallout 3, which features a vault dweller
in search of his father, Fallout 4 chronicles
a weird inverted Oedipal scenario where you
kill your son and destroy his legacy.
All Fallout games feature super mutants, Deathclaws,
and feral ghouls menacing the human race.
But in Fallout 4, there’s a new danger:
synthetic humans.
And while the perils of the Wasteland still
pose an existential threat to humankind, Fallout
4 introduces a new, purely philosophical threat
that is: What does it mean to be human?
Through the synths, the game makes us question
everything we know about our very humanity.
Welcome to this Wisecrack Edition on The Philosophy
of Fallout 4.
The synth-creating Institute serves as the
primary antagonist to the rest of the Commonwealth.
The Institute was built when the surviving
scientists of a fictionalized MIT, known as
CIT, dug themselves underground to shield
themselves from the ravages of the irradiated surface.
Dedicating themselves to research and the
advancement of humanity, they quickly scrapped
their plans to improve life on the surface,
and instead opted to create serene waterfalls
and creepy synthetic children.
The Institute’s synth program draws suspicion
from the inhabitants of the Wasteland, who
believe - correctly - that the Institute is
replacing their loved ones with synthetic counterparts.
It also sets them at odds with the Railroad,
who believe the synths are sentient and being
exploited by the Institute, and the Brotherhood
of Steel, who feel the synthetic humanoids
are another case of technology gone too far.
The fundamental question about synths, and
our relation to them, falls into two camps.
There’s “humanism,” a philosophy centered
on, surprise, the “human,” and “posthumanism,”
the deconstruction and decentering of what
it means to be human.
As the player, one choice faced in the game
is to believe, as Father does, that the synths
are mere robots.
Or you can believe, as the Railroad does,
that because they’ve developed sentience
they’re deserving of rights.
We could see the synth storyline as an uninspired,
lazy, cliche about discrimination,
but it also does a great job of exploring the line
between human and non-human.
Nowhere is this divide explored more explicitly
than in the ideology of the Brotherhood of
Steel and their opposition to the Institute.
The Brotherhood are, for lack of a better
term, synth racists;
"Shoot to kill!"
they believe the cybernetic organisms are an abomination to nature.
And it’s not just the fear of them being
used by the Institute to spy on society, even
the rebellious synths shepherded to freedom
by the Railroad are targets of Maxson’s soldiers.
Walking around Brotherhood territory with
Valentine, an early-version synth, subjects
you to a deeply unsettling level of harassment.
The Brotherhood ride around on the “Prydwen”
led by a guy named Arthur - a reference to
the ship and hero of the tales of King Arthur.
Their ranks emulate medieval Europe, with
titles like Knight, Paladin, Scribe and Squires.
This is perhaps the best indication of how
they perceive themselves: chivalrous knights
out to battle monsters and protect the helpless
remains of humanity and its purity.
The Brotherhood adopts a kind of classical
morality.
They believe in “the human” as a pure,
inherently valuable entity worth defending.
Conceived in a womb of a loving mother, au
natural, you get the idea
They can be roughly described as “humanist.”
Now, there’s a ton of different kinds of
humanisms who all believe different things,
but we’re really just using the term “humanist”
to stress a level of assumptions they share
with other humanists: that there is a basic
human nature, and that the human, as opposed
to the inhuman, are the primary subjects of
the world.
If the Brotherhood is so bothered by synths
- it’s because this amalgam of man and machine
threatens the very identity that defines them
and the humanity they seek to defend.
Long before the Brotherhood, humanity was
obsessed with defining themselves by what
they are not.
We’re not like animals because we use tools,
think abstractly, and use emojis.
Back in the days of Ancient Greece, this anxiety
mainly manifested itself in interspecies creatures
like centaurs and minotaurs.
The combination of species disrupted the traditional
boundaries of Greek society - between man
and animal, polis and nature, etc.
Today, that anxiety about the boundaries of
the “human” creeps into our relationship
with technology.
Instead of human vs animal, it’s more like
human vs animals/machines/microbes and holy
shit the world is scary stuff.
A quick survey of the scifi genre will reveal
a ton of movies scared shitless about human
genetic manipulation, machines overtaking
humans, machines f*cking humans.
You get the idea.
In her essay “The Cyborg Manifesto,” philosopher
Donna Haraway investigates our construction
of “the human” and how this chasm, between
“organism and machine,” is always enforced
by a kind of “border war.”
We defend the figure of the human against
degradations, impurities, infections, and so on.
It shouldn’t be surprising to learn that
back in the day, people argued dialysis that was
an unsavory attempt to play God, an unholy
marriage between man and machine.
Life-saving technologies are often considered
undignified.
"Is he still alright?"
'Oh, no, no, he has health problems."
"Uh huh."
In order to preserve their idea of a pure
humanity, the Brotherhood wants to exterminate
the synths, who threaten these boundaries.
The Brotherhood’s defense of “the human”
isn’t all that new, and their response to
synths isn’t too surprising.
They’re essentially railing against miscegenation,
or the mixing of races, using the same invocations
of purity and nature that have always worked
so well when being dicks to entire groups
of people.
However, the Brotherhood’s idea of “human”
is deeply flawed, and full of contradictions.
It’s here that Fallout gets pretty smart,
even if inadvertently.
The game, through the Brotherhood of Steel,
shows the distinction between human and inhuman
isn’t so black and white,
"I don't recognize you."
and calls into question several myths surrounding the very idea of “the human”.
The first myth the Brotherhood runs into is
about the purity of the human body - shunning
the mixture of flesh and machine as we discussed
earlier.
The problem is -- they’re literally cyborgs.
If you want to rail against the posthuman,
let’s talk about your suits of power armor
that you wear around everywhere.
The power armor enhances the human body like
any implant could - it can augment your vision,
your strength.
For Proctor Ingram, it even fills the void
of the missing legs she lost in battle.
For Haraway, this boundary is always a fiction,
and the biggest enforcers of the border between
human and inhuman are gleefully ignorant of
how porous that border is.
Those things that make us human - using tools,
language, etc., are seen in both apes and birds.
We’re also molded, according to Haraway,
by the environment.
In real life, the “pure” human body is
full of foreign DNA and bacteria.
Likewise, the radiation wreaking havoc on
the DNA of Wasteland survivors makes them
as “impure” as the synths created with
“untainted” DNA from Sean.
The second myth is about human nature and
morality.
Maxson argues against Danse’s humanity on
the grounds that: “Those ethics that it’s
striving to champion aren’t even its own.
They were artificially inserted in an attempt
to have it blend into society.”
For many humanists, there’s either a human
nature which makes us innately good, or at
the very least, a free will which enables
the possibility of ethics: unlike animals
or machines, we can “choose” to be virtuous.
Maxson criticizes Danse for having “artificially
inserted ethics”, the irony of this, coming
from a man raised in a heavily regimented
military organization where higher powers
dictate a code of ethics to a set of subordinates,
seems to be lost on him.
"If you intend to stay within our ranks, you need to obey our tennents without question."
For Haraway, our entire being is crafted by
the cultures, societies, and environment that
we come into contact with.
For instance, exploring Kellog’s memories,
and his traumatic upbringing, can tell us
as much about who he is as his cybernetic
implants.
If the Institute inserted a set of ethics
in Danse, is it all that different from the
ethics instilled in us by our parents, our
church, or our schools?
Technology invading human nature is a constant
fear in real society - and constitutes the
third myth espoused by the Brotherhood.
Using tools is what allowed us to evolve into
who we are today, and the technologies we
developed along the way like agriculture,
architecture, and manufacturing shaped us
as much as we shaped the world with them.
Before the synths, the Brotherhood manifested
this fear in their distrust of technology:
believing the pursuit of science to be a reckless
transcending of human limitations and control.
Yet, at no point does it register for them
that flying around a blimp stocked full of
nukes might also be an act of hubris.
The figure of the synth creates a rupture
in our understanding of the human, complicating
these myths.
For Haraway, this is a good thing: our rigid
conception of “human” is what allows people
to ostracize ghouls and enslave synths in
Fallout, and has justified centuries of oppression
against racialized others.
Haraway argues for a “cyborg politics”
one that rejoices “in the illegitimate fusion
of animal and machine.”
In other words, instead of denying that we
are cyborgs, we should embrace it.
We are not only the fusion of flesh and machine,
but society, history and culture.
The Institute, even if accidentally, manages
to confront us with this pollution of “the human."
Father leaves you a synthetic version of himself
for you to raise as your own child.
The Synths, who we’re told are mere automatons,
bristle for freedom regardless of their categorization.
Even the fact that Synth’s are built using
actual human DNA further blurs these boundaries.
Valentine, who is aware he is living with
somebody else’s memories planted into his
artificial mind, struggles with what it means
“to be” knowing that he, and his past,
are fabrications.
And there’s this
speech from Danse: “It’s true, I was built
within the confines of a laboratory, and some
of my memories aren’t my own.
But when I saw my brothers dying at my feet,
I felt sorrow.
When I defeated an enemy of the Brotherhood,
I felt pride.
Don’t you understand?
I thought I was human, Arthur.”
Perhaps the most interesting lesson we can
draw from Fallout 4 comes from the story of
Pinocchio.
In Pinocchio, a wooden marionette strives
to become fully human.
It’s only when he learns the human traits
of selflessness and honesty that he is finally
transformed.
Fallout offers us a few parallels: there’s
Curie, who wants to become a real human,
but settles for her brain being downloaded into
a synth.
Then there’s the relationship between Father
and the synth Shaun he built, which somewhat
parallels the relationship between Gepetto
and Pinnochio.
Both Danse and Valentine ground their claims
in humanity, like the story of Pinocchio,
in their human values.
And what better metaphor for what it means
to be human than a puppet who only becomes
a human after he learns to obey his father
and accept society’s rules?